welcome
everyone to yet another topic on junit
tutorial now in this one we are going to
talk about junit installation how we can
do the installation of junit and what
are the different steps we can get
involved on that now let's talk about
what exactly is the junit tool all about
like what are the different things we
can implement with the help of this tool
here
so junit is basically a kind of unit
testing framework which is there for the
java
so it's kind of a default offering for
the java programming language that we
can use the chair unit
for the unit testing framework for
performing the unit testing
now the main benefit of the junit is
like it's
using the same syntax like a java
programming language
so it makes it very easy for a java
developer to write and execute the test
cases
so most of the times when the developers
are going to work on the java
programming languages
so they prefer that junit as a default
unit testing framework for them because
they get the language advantage they get
the easily integrations and the eclipse
so those benefits helps the developers
to decide junit
specifically for writing the test cases
and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code
so all the unit test cases will be
executed will be again executed there
every time when you run a new build so
all the unit test cases gets executed
but you also need to take care that if
you are adding up a new functionalities
you also have to add the corresponding
test cases to that
so increasing more and more code will uh
will be done by the developers but at
the same time
you have to sync or you have to keep
your test cases up to date
also and as a part of every build each
and every test cases will be re-executed
every time you're doing the build five
times
six times a day every time the all unit
test cases will be executed over there
and the response will be given back
right now let's talk about what exactly
is the unit testing
now unit testing refers to the testing
of these small small modules or the
small piece of
chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to
have the early identification of the
defects and the bugs because
you cannot simply rely on the qa team to
perform the testing
and then provide the feedback whereas on
the uh with the help of this unit
testing framework we can
immediately get the feedback right away
once we are
running the test cases immediately we
will be able to know like these are the
different test cases which we have
got over here now the developers don't
even have to
spend more time on fixing the bugs and
issues because
these test cases will help them with the
easy and the fast feedback
so according to that they can fix the
bugs and they can take the decision
whether the
source code is working fine as expected
or there is any kind of
issues as such present with this one so
unit test casing is something which
is very important from the developer's
perspective also because it helps the
developers to understand that they
whether they have written a successful
code
or if there is any kind of scope of
issues or bugs over here
also it uh the successful unit test
cases uh
increases the overall confidence of the
developers because it uh
increases the overall uh performance and
the quality of the product also
so by having the successful executions
of the unit test cases
developers can understand that yes the
source code is working fine as expected
and there is no scope of bugs or any
issues as such with this source code
here
so that's the main benefit which we get
with unit testing that with this
fast feedback channel we will be able to
take uh
the decisions whether the source code is
ready for the production environment
deployment or not so that's a main
benefit
which we get with the unit testing here
now of course this can be done in two
ways manual testing and automatic
testing now in case of manual testing
you have to do this thing manually
within a manual tester or a manual
testing approach
and in this one you will not be
depending on any kind of automated tool
which can be scheduled or which can be
executed in non-interactive manner on
the other hand automatic test case is
something which
uh is used to be executed using the
tool and uh it is something which is
being done so that you will be able to
get
the complete automation there is no
manual efforts which is required
as such you are going to have like
complete uh deployment and automations
being done
as such in this case so automated
testing is something in which you will
be giving more focus on the automated
automation tools
you may be having one or a couple of
tools which using which you can write
the
automated test cases and you can perform
the complete automation
in case of manual testing it's quite uh
you know less reliable because
you are dependent on the uh a particular
tester
which can ha perform the testing
according to his
efforts and it's quite a time consuming
also because you can only run the test
cases for
probably eight to nine hours per a day
whereas on the other hand the automated
test case is something which is
quite reliable because it does not
depends on a human so so requirements so
it can be done like 24
7 so anytime you can run those test
cases and that's the reason why these
test cases are quite faster
as compared to any other manual testing
approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases
really helps the developers and the qa
professionals to test the
source code much faster as compared to
the manual testing
now let's talk about the joint
installation now as part the of the
installation of junit you don't require
to install any exe file or any kind of
program there
there are a couple of jar files which is
required which needs to be there into
the
class path so that every time when you
write some junit test cases you should
be able to refer those jar files
because without having those jar files
into your class part of your project
you will not be able to run the change
in test cases so
that's the only dependency you require
if you are running a maven build
then these dependencies will be added up
into the powered xml file
if you are referring or doing the build
from the eclipse or
doing the development from the ecrips
then you have to put up these jar files
into the
class part of the project so that these
jar files can be loaded up and dj unit
can be referred over here
so the installation is pretty straight
forward but let's see like what are the
different steps we need to follow
now as a pre-request of understanding
the demo about junit the first initial
two things is
like you require a jdk to be installed
now you can download the jdk8 over here
from this oracle website
and uh this is something which you can
download for the windows or whatever
platform you have
you can pretty much install it for
whatever platform is there
so for windows platform you can download
for 32-bit and the 64-bit both option
over here
and once it's installed so you should be
able to use the eclipse latest tool
now um all you need to do is that you
need to go to eclipse.org
and there you can download the latest
version of the
eclipse now these two main things which
you require because
eclipse will be required for creating
the change unit test cases and of course
how a kind of id where you can run some
test cases change your test cases and
all
and then oracle is something which is
required as a runtime for
running the jdk also and the junit uh
test cases also and eclipse here so
that's a pre-request which we got over
here in this one
so i have already got these two things
installed into my system and i have
eclipse there so let's move on to the
eclipse and see that how it going goes
on there
but before that you also require the
junit jar files because
in order to have a particular junit
framework loaded up
we require some uh particular files
jar files over here in this case so i
can just search for junit
four over here and when you search for j
unit four so what happens like
this particular page will help you or
give you all the details about the
unit 4. now you can go for the version
notes of the different different
versions but uh if you want to download
all you need to do is like you can say
like download and install
and the moment you go there so it will
give you the details now there are two
jar files which is required
junit dot jar file is required over here
j uh hamcrest hyphen code.jar file these
two jar files are required here
if you want to download it into the test
class path if
you feel that you want to uh use a maven
based uh project then in that case
you have to specifically go for this
dependency in the palm file
and according to that that particular
version will be downloaded and will be
referred over there
so these are the ways that how you can
get the particular softwares the
required things into the place so i'm
going to put up this jar files into a
location so that
i should be able to get the particular
details
stored and i can refer to them into my
eclipse
so i'm going to download this one here
from the
maven central
so i'm going to download this jar file
and then i'm going to go back
and create hyphen code so that also i
want to download
download chart so these two jar files i
have uh
downloaded and i will be referring these
ones into my project
because these are the ones which has
been required into my project as such
so let's go back to the eclipse and uh
let's place this jar files into a
location so that
into my class path i can refer the
complete folder with all these two jar
files inside that so let's go ahead with
that
so let's create a particular new project
over here so we'll go for new
java project and here i can give it like
a simple one
a simple project name i can provide here
and
jdk i'm using like 1.8 so that's the jdk
version which i have utilized over here
and then folish so this is the project
which i have got like in the source
directory
now i'm going to create a simple uh file
over here
a new class file over here so i'll
create it like
j unit class
so i'm going to create a class over here
in this one
and of course i need to have a
particular white main also over here in
this
specific class over here because this is
the initial class i'm trying to create
over here in this one
i can create a custom uh particular
methods also over here but uh let's see
like if we can execute or we can run
some particular functions as such over
here now i'm going to declare
a function over here public
void junit
method so i'm just going to create
a method over here
i'm just going to run a particular
print statement over here
executing j unit
test cases right
now this is a kind of a method which is
there which of course i can run into my
uh public void main and this function
will be executed
will be called upon over here now the
thing is that uh
right now uh since it's just a normal
function but the moment
i convert it like i have uh
at the rate test mentioned over here so
what will happen like this will be
converted into the form of a test cases
now of course like right now there is no
imports which is available there
as part of this one so you can see that
the uh the
the time i have added this annotation at
the read test
i will be able to see like yes add
junit 4 library to the build path
is something which is coming up over
here or it's saying like at
j unit 5. so whatever the library you
feel that you want to add you can do
that
and that particular library will be
added up okay now let's go for the junit
4 library here the moment i do that what
will happen
you will see some changes first you will
see the changes in the top
saying that import orj dot junit dot
test
that's a first import and second import
will be like junit 4 you will see like
these two jar files
is automatically being picked up by the
eclipse
now even if you don't download these jar
files this is the main benefit of the
eclipse that these are already
a part of the plugins you can see their
paths that these are already installed
in the
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more plugins directory so the
moment you use
these uh particular methods that you
want to use the junit
these will be automatically imported
over here into your system
now you can just simply call this method
into the main
void mean and then the specific method
will be executed as a form of test cases
so this is the mechanism that how you
will be
setting up the project initially you got
the imports you got the
uh particular annotations configured and
with that
the uh specific jar files will be
automatically being added up into your
class path
whatever the java files we added up we
downloaded previously we can also
have that added up into the custom class
path we can modify this
build path of junit 4 which is coming up
automatically we can just simply say
right click
build path and configure so this jf unit
4 we can actually import we can remove
it from our system and we can
add our external jar files also into the
build path or the class path over here
so that depends upon you
that how you want to perform the
customizations around that part but yes
the particular main benefit of using the
eclipse is that it's already having the
junit plugin installed
both four and five version is installed
whatever version you feel that you want
to include
it will be included and the plugins are
already installed so you don't even have
to download
the jar files manually so that's how you
will be able to do a very basic initial
setup of junit and how a basic project
can be created over here in case of
chair unit
so that's it for this topic thanks
everyone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here